President Biden
in one
of his
most definitive statements
to date moments ago, making it c
United States
aid will continue to pour into U
So is it open ended for now?
Yeah, it is.
Look, there's no way
that Putin is going to be able t
He's already lost Ukraine.
Made it clear.
Is it open ended yet?
It is not a pause, no hesitation
It's clear where he stands.
And this comes
as we're getting new video in to
showing a top of the line. U.S.
artillery shell
called the Excalibur
in action in Ukraine.
And it is incredibly precise.
Take a look at this video
that we have obtained.
You see what is described as Rus
awesome missile defense system.
It's hidden inside that building
And then in a split second, the
and the air defense system all b
Flames engulfing
what is left of that structure.
CNN is reporting that the Ukrain
have been using these Excalibur,
which the United States
began supplying just a few month
with great success.
Right.
And now it's open ended more and
And just look at these videos.
These show the Excalibur
blowing up Russian tanks.
These lethal strikes
are not just taking a massive
toll on Putin's
tanks, though,
but, of course, on Russian soldi
to the daily death toll now
in the hundreds.
And the new weapons are hurting.
Putin's already
deeply challenged efforts
to recruit more manpower.
Just here,
this new report,
according to the Russian
independent media site against
Putin's government, is now
threatening prisoners
who refuse to fight in the war
with new charges and longer sent
In fact,
they're saying
even threatening to charge them
with offenses
that maybe 20 years
in the past allegations.
The reason
is that many prisoners now
are saying, no,
they don't want to go
fight on the front lines,
even if that means getting out
of their penal colonies in jail
Reportedly
because they now
have heard of the number of Russ
dying on the battlefield.
Putin needs these bodies fast
because we understand
that the largest number of priso
facing these threats of go
or else are in the regions
bordering Ukraine
in those very regions,
so that they can make the threat
and get them to the front line f
Forget all those training stops
or anything even resembling that
All of this
reporting comes
in the context
of what Putin seems to be doing,
which is pushing right now
a new offensive near Kharkiv,
an area
where Ukraine was able to drive
the Russians out just a few mont
And just when you thought
the Russian government wouldn't
or couldn't stoop any lower.
CNN's Tim Lister and team
are now reporting
that this man, a former Chechen
wanted for alleged war crimes in
is now leading Russia's
earthquake relief effort in Turk
It's not a joke,
according to Ukraine's security
Danielle
Martin of
was behind the occupation
of a Ukrainian psychiatric hospi
in March.
It said that on his orders,
almost 500
people were taken hostage,
including more than 100
bedridden patients.
The hospital was
then turned into a firing positi
for Russians.
And now that's the guy
leading Russia's
relief efforts in Turkey.
And it comes as the Kremlin
is upping threats
against the entire world
tonight, warning of military
and political ramifications.
Their exact words,
if the United Kingdom sends
British jets
to Ukraine,
The threat coming on the same da
Zelensky visited London
and it only his second time outs
Ukraine since Putin invaded.
You can see what's the landscape
Receiving a hero's welcome.
He then addressed a joint sessio
of parliament.
What he asked for was the fighte
I appeal to you and the world wa
And yet most important words
combat aircrafts for Ukraine.
Wings for freedom,
wings for freedom, he calls them
And the British prime
minister's office says
the UK is actively
considering this request.
Fred Pleitgen
begins our coverage OUTFRONT
live in Kiev tonight.
And Fred,
what is the latest
you're seeing on the front lines
Well, there certainly is a big u
in shelling that we're seeing,
especially in the
northeast of the country.
You were talking about Harkov
just a couple of moments ago.
And that really is
where a lot of that is taking pl
Of course, it's really unclear
whether or not
that new Russian offensive
really is already in full swing.
But in general,
in the east of the country,
the Russians certainly have been
a lot of forces
and using a lot more firepower.
And that's lead to eight waste
entire towns in eastern Ukraine.
Here's what we're seeing
Ukrainian towns
getting decimated by Russian fir
every day.
This is Marine
in the east of the country,
almost completely reduced to rub
around to combat at close quarte
as Ukrainian troops try to preve
Russian fighters
of the Virginia
private military company
from encircling the city.
Wagner boss
Yevgeny Prigozhin,
so confident in his own
private air force,
he took to the skies
and challenged
Ukraine's president to a dog fig
Tomorrow, I'm boarding a MiG 29,
he said, if you desire.
We'll meet in the sky to speak.
But Ukraine's
president Vladimir Zelensky, is
visiting the UK's parliament,
pleading for Western combat jets
In Britain, the King
is a near force pilot.
And in Ukraine today, every Air
Force pilot is a king.
Despite being much smaller
and older
than Moscow's Air Force,
the Ukrainians are still very mu
in the fight in the skies
but they're losing planes
and having trouble
maintaining their Soviet fleet.
Just going to get in a car.
Even a small number of Western
fighters would make a big differ
Says Ukraine's Air Force spokesm
The families of Russian officers
we can start with a few squadron
he says, each with 12 jets.
If we have one to two or more, s
it would be the first step
for our pilots to transition.
They can be information
and perform combat missions
on different directions.
The U.S.
has given the Ukrainians
some air
launched anti-radiation
missiles called harm.
But Kiev says those two would wo
much better
if launched from Western jets.
Just landed to get the air.
Missiles aren't as efficient
as if they were used
from American or other allied ai
the spokesman says.
Their functionality is restricte
and the range is shorter,
making the efficiency lower.
Ukrainian
officials say they want us made
So far,
President Biden has ruled out
giving Kiev combat aircraft But
says it will soon
start training Ukrainian pilots.
And Ukrainian officials
tell CNN they're confident
they'll get jets
just like eventually
they got the main
battle tanks
they requested before dealership
We'd like help as soon as possib
like yesterday, he says.
And our partners say
it will come tomorrow.
And the space between yesterday
and tomorrow is very important t
And Ukraine's civilians remain
in the crosshairs of Russia's
cannons, missiles and jets.
While Kiev hopes for more Wester
to start beating them back
And of course, Erin,
the Ukrainians are well aware of
that if these jets come, if the
and its allies
give jets to Ukraine, that's som
that's going to happen
in the longer term.
That could take months.
It could take a couple of years.
But President Vladimir
Zelensky today
in the United Kingdom
also said
Ukraine needs more immediate
help, longer range missiles.
Very important right now
with that offensive looming,
but also more armor.
The Ukrainians say that will hel
withstand that offensive
and then possibly go on a counte
offensive as well Erin.